this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we have a
cosmic queries Edition from our
portfolio of let's make America smart
again the topic today vaccines and we
have one of the world's most
knowledgeable people on the intersection
of vaccines and the public's reaction to
it Laurie Garrett Laurie welcome to
Startalk thank you thanks for this not
your first rodeo no you did your your
third time with us I had you for one
build and I had you for another yeah the
first time I think we talked about the
zombie apocalypse and Bill Nye you
talked about Ebola right so this time we
talked about vaccine so thanks for
coming back you bet and my co-host
first-timer yeah I'm excited let me get
your name right here
Felicia Madison you got it we should
welcome to Startalk thank you for having
your stand-up comedian and a producer of
comedy I am that's a wonderful thing and
you also make sure to remind me you are
mom I am plus you're married to want a
fourth kid that's right baby
the biggest baby my big baby gotta love
them and you you produce what is
laughing affairs what is that it's a
company that produces comedy shows okay
corporations I do a lot of charity event
nice yeah okay we'll keep looking for
you out there you want to have an affair
make sure it's a laughing one oh very
nice
tagline so this is cosmic queries we
have solicited questions from our
audience on the topic of vaccines which
is always in the news especially lately
and I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding about it and and Laura
you're here to set the record straight
and let me remind people if I did my
homework right you want a Pulitzer Prize
for your coverage of the Ebola virus I
did as a as a science journalist and
right now you're with what's the
American foreign policy
your science journalist for foreign
policy this is great we need more
science journalists out there who tell
it like it is
not how people want it to be yeah whoo
that's what she looks really upset what
are you doing here get back out there
and keep working so Felicia what
questions you have yeah yeah first
question is from Kela Helia silvus from
patreon patreon yeah just kissing ass
there yeah we love patreon right right
thank you I think if you're paté
remember we read your question first you
gotta go first
therefore so I'm Coolio silvus not me
but she's saying that a neuroscientist
from Minneapolis Minnesota
what public health policy
recommendations would you recommend to
combat the growing anti-vaxxers yes the
movement is growing unfortunately and so
yes there are more anti-vaxxer than
there were five years ago ten years ago
what have you and that's bad news the
problem is that more and more of the
anti-vaccine movement is not specific to
vaccines it's actually more an
anti-government movement a lack of trust
in governance which extends to include
science and scientific admonishments
that may come from government sources
whether it's public health leaders or
you know organized medicine
what-have-you and it makes the battle of
fighting this inappropriate incorrect
perspective about the role of vaccines
in saving lives
it makes fighting it very very difficult
because you're not really fighting to
the message you're fighting to a larger
social problem a larger political
problem that very few people in public
health are prepared to address they
don't have the skills they're very
uncomfortable with politics very
uncomfortable with talking about you
know why why for example is the
anti-vaccine movement on one side that
would be the sort of Texas Missouri deep
south side very tightly linked to Donald
Trump and his politics whereas the
anti-vaccine
movement on the other side that would be
places like Seattle Portland Northern
California very tightly linked to kind
of a suspicion of government and drug
companies coming from a sort of Whole
Earth Catalog place how do you reconcile
those and fight both of them how do you
deal with the fact that in Italy the
five star movement a decidedly populist
very right-wing movement has taken over
the Italian government and they are as
part of their platform opposed to all
vaccines how do you deal with the fact
that one of the rising right-wing
populist movements of France has as part
of its catalog opposition to vaccines so
you're bumming us out here I don't so
what she was what solutions you just
said it's worse than we ever thought and
we should just give up well if it were
I'm paraphrasing you just said I know I
well I didn't find it she did but my
point is we had a moment of opportunity
maybe ten years ago when opposition was
really about dealing with the facts it
was really about addressing specific
concerns people had about vaccines and
today it's more and more disconnected
from any kind of fact base at all and
has more to do with kind of general
political suspicions we're asking you
for a solution here so I mean if we do
want to address the facts and we do want
to get people on board you know one of
the big problems we have to deal with in
rich countries like the United States is
that most people haven't really seen
someone with measles they haven't really
seen a child face diphtheria they
haven't actually seen any of these
diseases and so they've grown very
nonchalant about it and it's easy to get
cavalier
we even had Darla shine who's the wife
of the White House communications
director bill shine who has been
tweeting that it's good for you to have
measles you should get your children
exposed to all these and they should get
sick with all of them because she who of
course has no medical training falsely
claims that they protect you from cancer
so we have all kinds of disinformation
out there that should needs to be
constantly countered and we have a
fantastic toolkit available
multiple sites online books etc to help
you know how to give the correct
information regarding the efficacy of
vaccines and their safety it's that it's
that famous so you use a anti dandruff
shampoo and I come to you and I say why
do you use an anti dinner shampoo you
don't have any dandruff right so do you
just have poster children who are
completely infected with vaccine
preventable diseases and say this could
be your kid well one of the things that
has been happening is more and more
parents of children with cancer are
coming forward going online going on
Facebook and so on and saying please
vaccinate your children because my
child's immune system has been
devastated me and if your child is a
carrier my child will die right and yeah
at that point becomes a very serious
public health thing cuz it doesn't
affect you alone it affects other people
that's right because it's about herd
immunity so this is the other herd
immunity so this is the other reason
that it gets so balled up with politics
because what public health is really
saying to the masses out there is hey if
98% of you get a measles vaccine
properly and your booster properly then
the good news is the whole society is
protected the herd is immune mm-hmm
because for measles which is the most
contagious human pathogen there is we
need about a 98% level of immune
protection to protect the whole herd so
that child with cancer for example is
protected if 98% of the other kids have
been immunized but if as soon as that
herd immunity Falls gets down and in
some parts of the United States where
resistance is high people oppose
vaccines it's down to the 50% level you
know which is insane which is zero herd
immunity
this is only individual immunity but
presumably there are other kinds of
diseases that don't require 98 percent
that's right that protection influenza
influenza is that 50% protection because
it cuts off and it cuts off if if you
have half the exposure and these are not
people you're necessarily close to you
can get through it without catching it
right well no there's a we have this
this concept of reproductive rate and
that has to do with if if you have the
flu and you're coughing and you're sick
in this room right now which better not
be true then you odds are statistically
would infect three people in this room
as a matter of pure statistics so the
reproductive rate is 3 if it's measles
the reproductive rate is 15 to 18 so
people in a crowded room yeah so in
other words you know there are how many
of us here in this room right now five
so it's just purely statistically
speaking if I had measles and you folks
weren't vaccinated every one of you
would get measles from being in this
room with me and here's another way of
looking at it measles one of the things
that makes its reproductive rates so
horrible is it's airborne and the virus
can linger in a space and successfully
infect somebody who comes in later I can
leave this room a Neil's office and is a
site of contagion for everybody else
that walks in you can leave this room
and yet you'll still be here all right
next question
patreon one right now Brett LaRue in the
future if we were able to travel to
other planets with a breathable
atmosphere what would be the steps to
vaccinate against the unknown dangers
you know who first thought about that
Joshua Lederberg who was a Nobel
laureate one of the Great's was at
Rockefeller University for many years
and he thought about it when
he was when I think at the time the
youngest Nobel laureate in history I
think he was like 33 or 34 something
unbelievable and I Miri Curie I was
pretty young
yeah well and he had you know discovered
the first examples of antibiotic
resistance so one of the things Josh
Lederberg said was wow we're sending men
to the moon what if we you know
unwittingly took our microbes to the
moon with those men to the moon and
infected a life-form if there is any on
the moon or conversely what if there is
some kind of microbial life on moon and
those guys bring it back with them right
so so that was the beginning of Michael
Crichton's book Andromeda Strain loved a
book and the movie yeah and you know
that has been a constant question just
for those who didn't know in the
Andromeda Strain there is a space probe
that returns to earth but it had been
contaminated by a space virus right
and it basically killed everyone in the
town where this thing landed and it
became a major public health issue
how to deal with it what they're doing
why was it militarized was it a project
what was going on so very a fascinating
topic michael crichton the same author
of Jurassic Park yes yeah so um so
that's that prompted NASA to look at
this problem and it's been constantly
revisiting the problem and in fact in
the current space station now there's a
whole mic division of NASA the the
division of planetary protection will
you protect where you're going and you
protect Earth coming back right just in
response to this and in the current
space station you know we had the twins
the twin brothers the Kelly's who were I
did that one on Startalk yes I don't
know which one it was the better-looking
[Music]
one of them was in space and was the
longest American and while his brother
was on earth and one of the things they
did was test their own microbiome every
single day so that on earth were one is
to keeping track of what microbes are
inside his body and in space the other
is keeping track of his mm-hmm and you
saw an actual clear change in space
while it's possible for an invading
species and invading virus or bacterium
to completely take out in a whole
population that has no immunity to it
such as what happened when the explorers
went back and forth from Europe to North
America and back all right there was
smallpox there was what's the other one
well influenza smallpox syphilis oh yes
syphilis actually went back to Europe
right so so there's and then it infects
people but the difference is there are
human beings on both sides of the ocean
all right
so an interesting point of safety is can
you catch a disease that has no
experience in your species at all right
like so for example it can can an oak
tree catch whooping cough answer no
maybe that Wizard of Oz trees can catch
ripping clocks another way of asking
that is why do we assume that a foreign
life-form an alien life-form would have
a four base pair DNA cottage exactly yes
the kinds of biochemistry to match and
marry with our biochemistry so that
anything can happen at all so right so
it may be safer than we otherwise
thought but I'd rather be on the safest
side by putting in these precautions and
of course the 2019 the fiftieth
anniversary of the Apollo 11 landing
when they came back they were put in
quarantine and a little what he called
it it's not a Winnebago nobody called
the Quonset hut you know there was a
silver version recall the silver ones
about the jet stream I love this game
I'll say it say something stream they
were crowded near the little window
looking out to have a conversation with
people just to keep them quarantined and
I would always worried me was well wait
a minute they had to get into that
somehow the other side was War of the
Worlds the premise was what saved the
world was that the invader got infected
by an earthly virus exactly exactly
can't creepy turn it Zack well it so
funny you mentioned War of the Worlds I
keep with me a quote from the original
book that summarizes the entire story
and if you with your permission I will
read it please do as we take out this
first segment of Startalk cosmic queries
let's make America smart again for so it
had come about as indeed I and many men
might have foreseen had not terror and
disaster blind at our minds these germs
of disease have taken toll of humanity
since the beginning of things taken toll
of our pre-human ancestors since life
began here but by virtue of this natural
selection of our kind we have developed
resisting power to no germs do we
succumb without a struggle and to many
those that cause putrefaction in dead
matter for instance our living forms are
altogether immune but there are no
bacteria on Mars and directly these
invaders arrived directly they drank and
fed our microscopic allies began to work
their overthrow already when I watched
them they were irrevocably doomed dying
and rotting even as they went to and fro
it was inevitable by the toll of a
billion deaths man has bought his
birthright of this earth and it is his
against all comers it would still be his
with our Martians ten times as mighty as
they are for neither do men live nor die
in vain chills needle this novel was
written after the astronomer Percival
Lowell reported that he believed he saw
canals on the surface of Mars and
published them and this was headline
news there Martians up there hgl says I
will make some money off of that
out came war the world a year later two
years later out came the novels when we
come back more of cosmic queries the
vaccine Edition on Startalk
back on Startalk let's make America
smart again cosmic queries addition
vaccines Laurie Garrett vaccine
professional extraordinaire
no you're just it's not so much vaccines
is you're just good about all diseases
yeah how does that go at the bar the
best way to kill romance is just start
talking about deadly pathogens a deadly
pathogen yeah Alicia Madison come on
down what's the next question the next
contestant is they'll jocks on Twitter
what is the main driver that causes
parents not to vaccinate their children
these days well today the number one
driver what would that be um doubting
the safety of the vaccines themselves
okay and wasn't there a time when some
people refused them on religious grounds
that continues that's ongoing right
right now we have an outbreak in New
York City that's among Hasidic Jews
because there's a very high level of
opposition religiously vaccines and our
nation has always respected religious
rules provided that didn't infringe on
other people's freedoms so are they more
likely to is a public health agency more
likely to allow a religious person to
not vaccine rather than someone who's
just fears the vaccine well you know the
thing is the religious objections was
like less than 1% of the populations
that was okay but now 17 states have
created a category called philosophical
objection and that means pretty much
anybody it's the catch basin of any
argument you have yeah Wow okay sounds
like something my kids are gonna say to
me against needles yeah if your kid says
I'm philosophically object it's like
that's kind of like you have no rebuttal
to that because they've thought about it
they just don't want to go to school
sorry objective school
because you have to fill out these
forums that you can't go to school if
you don't get that's right it's
depending on the state you live in oh
really mm-hmm
is there a state that is most egregious
in this matter well Texas is way up
there no state of Washington is way up
there although there now because of
their current measles outbreak state of
Washington has a bill before the state
legislature supported by the governor
that would eliminate the philosophical
objection so what you're saying is
echoing how we started this this show
people now see their kids and their
friends have measles they're more likely
to vote differently than if you live in
a world with no measles so Disneyland
2014 Mickey Mouse at all measles it
spreads because of a visitor who's
infected and all the not vaccinated
people in Disneyland then dispersed all
over the country California at that time
had philosophical objection
possibilities the state boomerang the
legislature and the governor all said
okay we eliminate all this you can't go
to school unless you're vaccinated now
California has one of the lowest rates
of vaccine preventable disease in the
nation hmm so it just took a real
example it took a real example something
you need a better PR campaign you know
it's what you need you need you need mr.
measles you know I mean just to be a
sober for a moment I'm one of the few
people that could say as an American
I've actually held a child in my arms
that died of measles in my arms there's
very few people in my generation and
certainly in younger generations that
have ever even seen the disease and
doctors today have a hard time
diagnosing diphtheria or whooping cough
or you know even chickenpox say they
they just haven't seen them and it
creates a lot of resistance in the
public mind
you know my favorite objection which I
have often heard is you know it's not
that I think there's any the most
laughable objection no it's it's the one
that's kind of
in chic vogue at the moment okay is it's
not that there's anything specifically
some nasty chemical in the vaccine it's
just that they're giving too many
vaccines my children can't take so many
they need to space them out more they
can't you know right and I always say
look a baby has only two jobs two jobs
one look at everything and listen to
everything to finish the hardwiring of
your brain and to learn language and you
know what's going on in your world and
the second job pick everything up and
stick it in your mouth lick it
slobber all over it grab another kids
slobber all over them your programming
your immune system in any given day a
kid is picking up more junk off the
floor and throwing it in to program
their immune system than is contained in
all the various shots they will have for
their entire life nowadays infants
aren't getting all that though cuz
parents are crazy but if what we know is
if you don't do the grovel on the floor
you stick the dirt in your face you end
up with asthma you end up with
autoimmune diseases because you've never
properly got your immune system knowing
what is foreign and what is friend my
sister has a barn and she makes sure
when they had their kid had the kid
crawl around the floor yeah he's not he
doesn't get sick he he has he's the guy
all his friends have all these allergies
he's got no allergies
I wear dove third children are healthier
than the first children because of that
oh nothing that touches the first kid
but the third kid the parents are like
go whatever whatever we should study
that Felicia next one next question okay
Alana from start talk radio net I
understand that science points to the
benefits of vaccines but there's still
so much fear and disbelief as to their
benefits versus harm I would like to
know why they use the chemicals and
preservatives they use aluminum
formaldehyde coloring polysorbate why
that why haven't they moved forward with
better vaccine technology and what is
the real statistics around the
effectiveness versus injury and children
and adults long question well let me
take the preservative
part because that is the objection that
has been most commonly raised amongst
those that fear there's a contaminant
that will poison their child and then
separate from the vaccine itself yeah
that's used because you want the vaccine
to be stored you don't want to have to
make it every day right right you know
and especially when you're going
overseas into humid hot climates and so
on you need you need vaccine to be able
to withstand a range of temperatures and
so on in the past we're talking 1950s
1960s 1970s there were some
preservatives used that contain mercury
methyl mercury and ethyl mercury and
there were some that contained as the
mercury family and there were you know
other preservatives used but they've
been greatly greatly reduced and in fact
all the mercury containing ones were
banned by the FDA quite a long time ago
and worldwide mostly what's done has
more to do with the storage and how you
store the vaccines then what
preservatives you put in the vaccine so
we've greatly reduced all of those
threats isn't it true that some percent
of children who are vaccine who receive
a vaccine will have an adverse effect
what percent is that it depends on the
vaccine and on the child's health at the
time they receive a vaccine and also
what you're calling an adverse effect a
lot of people get a swollen arm wherever
they get injected is that an adverse
effect well not one that anybody should
be worried about right that under and
some child may complain of a headache
did they have the headache already
before they got vaccinated did the
vaccine give them a headache or was it
the experience of screaming in the
doctor's office that gave them a
headache but the adverse event
or give you a lollipop finish my kids
screaming that gives me a headache
but the adverse events problem is very
very very very very very very low this
is a scientific program so I'm
interested in you quantifying the fly
varies the the problem is it's based on
the vaccine mm-hmm the specific
percentage the kids die
the only deaths that we've seen
associated with vaccines have been at
least in contemporary time have been
with inappropriately manufactured
products in India and China and in fact
China has reached a point where they've
they've made so many bad batches of
vaccine that have harmed so many
children that now they've had public
executions of vaccine makers they have
imprisoned vaccine makers and a lot of
parents are refusing to use locally made
vaccines and are trying to get American
vaccines for their children okay all
right Felicia okay next this is not a
question but Barry Fallon from facebook
says all patents should be removed from
vaccines and medication so let's ask
about that what's the what's the ethics
of having a cure for something and maybe
you spent a billion dollars for that
first pill and but now I want to recoup
but it's gonna save lives well let me
take that apart first on the vaccine
side there's no drug company getting
rich off vaccines it's such a tiny tiny
piece of the profit pile and a lot of
companies in fact are abandoning making
vaccines our real danger is that it's
concentrated down to just four
corporations on the planet that are
really making vaccines because it's so
low profit on the drug side we have
another whole story okay
and so maybe yeah without a doubt
there's profiteering in the manufacture
of pharmaceuticals and you're gonna have
hearings on Capitol Hill about it you're
gonna see that it's across the board
politically everybody's mad so we need
some public health guidance we need some
ethical
since that doesn't completely remove the
profit motive there's gotta be some
middle ground but you know here's the
thing when that people blame patents and
believe me I'm not a big defender but
when they blame patents they fail to
notice that right now the biggest
profiteering skyrocketing is in the
generics industry you know you all heard
that fellow shkreli he's now gone to
prison well he was buying up generic
manufacturing it was off patent all
right Felicia okay to me this is my
favorite question okay it's from Daniel
J Saltzman from Instagram can we create
a vaccine to eliminate people that are
against vaccines let's add that to this
one but from Wilhemina van I can't even
pronounce your last name D ijk and he
guesses how you pronounce that yeah yeah
from Facebook can science ever undo the
damage caused by the anti-vaxxers and
their celebrity spokespeople well that's
very much like the very first nation we
had in the first segment today because
well the first one was asking about
policy but now we're talking about
popular the power of popularity as a
face of a movement you know we have a
lot of celebrities out there you know
Jim Carrey and so on they're
anti-vaccine what we don't have are a
lot of very prominent celebrities coming
out saying yay vaccinate your kids and
let me show you my children I've had
each one of them vaccinated for
everything according to doctors
recommendations and that's a shame we
could really use those voices yeah
that's life in general though there were
always the naysayers or never like the
positive ones let's do this let's do
this it's like let's not do this there's
just the complainers I mean think about
do you remember a Michele Bachmann yeah
mmm she ran for president United States
what three times ago three rounds ago
and she claimed that the HPV vaccine
which protected you against the virus
that causes cervical cancer that that
caused mental retardation and she said
that she in one of the
presidential debates she claims she knew
someone whose child had become had
mongol ism as a result of being
vaccinated with HPV well first of all
it's utterly ludicrous that you don't
develop trisomy 21 a genetic disease as
a result of a vaccine and you're
administering the vaccine at age
fourteen so are you saying that for
fourteen years she was you know without
thank you to me twenty-one but it but
but it was utterly absurd and in fact a
lot of the far-right opposes the HPV
vaccine mainly because there's this
crazy idea that if you're protected
against a sexually transmissible disease
you'll go out and have more sex you know
it's the same crazy notion that said you
shouldn't use condoms or promote condoms
because then everybody out there and
have more sex because they have condoms
and that's why I'm not getting HPV
vaccine right I don't have to go out
there and have more sex now we go all
these years later and we could see all
over the world a dramatic decline in
cervical cancer I mean this vaccine has
is the first genuine anti-cancer vaccine
on the planet and its efficacy is
absolutely I'm getting goose bumps even
thinking about it because I've lost I
lost a dear friend to cervical cancer I
watched her suffer and die and if only
that vaccine had been available just a
few years earlier she might have been
with us today people are afraid I was
afraid to give my kids the vaccine
because you don't know right but what
are you afraid of it's new you don't
know the effects of it we're gonna find
out more when she's afraid of after this
break on Startalk cosmic queries the
vaccine edition when we return
Startalk we're back let's make America
smart again cosmic queries vaccines
Laurie Garrett always good to have you
it's got a happy gonna have anymore
I love it excellent and Felicia of my
co-hosts first timer the first timer
excellent been unplugged you were just
saying that your you were resistant to
vaccinating your kids against the human
papilloma virus I was very nervous
mainly for my youngest one who had a pet
psoriasis and they said that if you have
an autoimmune disease it could be
dangerous
I've heard stories about we said that
yeah who said that a girl that had it
like you said a reaction which could
have been totally about I was just
nervous for her it kind of makes sense
if you ever do I did good and why um I
did a little research and everyone that
I spoke to that was knowledgeable in the
field said I had one or two people that
still said no but I basically decided
the risk outweighed I joked around that
I told my daughter's outweigh the risks
yeah I told my daughter that you know
you have 16 year old the little one and
the older if I if there's a vaccine that
if you have sex before you could die of
cancer and the doctors busy for about
six years from having sex so how about
your sons so my son then it came out
that you should give it to your son's
also and I decided that he was older at
the time I let him make the decision and
the doctor was talking to him about it
and telling him the risks and he said he
could prevent you from getting giving
someone cancer could prevent you from
getting cancer he was undecided and they
just said in and it could prevent you
from having warts on your balls he's
like I'll get it decide to go forward
with it cosmetic
okay large warts on the books I'm gonna
have it but but people were nervous and
there I remember of my schools there's a
lot of controversy and meetings and
people talking about it and there were
experts saying you should definitely do
it definitely do it and the detractors
were saying that the doctors get paid by
the pharmaceutical companies to push it
oh yeah yeah you know what we've seen
worldwide is such a dramatic reduction
in the numbers of women all over the
world dying of cervical carcinoma it's
it's astronomical and good work on this
program yeah you know when I was young
and very you know a teenage sexually
active teenager the only protection we
had against cervical cancer other than
trying to convince a partner to use a
condom was getting routine pap smears
well the pap smear is actually detecting
that you already have it you know so
it's already showing that cells are
beginning to transform and at the very
least you have what's called dysplasia
pre-cancer in in your cervix or a
cervical area so that's that's like oh
the horse is already running down the
hill you know somebody please lock up
the barn it's like the radiation badge
you wear in nuclear power plants right
it's you hand it and say okay you were
exposed today in 18 hours oh thank you
turn black happy news yeah whereas now
people are tested for the presence of
HPV viruses and so you're actually not
like waiting to see do you have
transformed cells you're waiting to see
gee are you infected with the virus that
will transform those cells and lead to
cancer and good news is we have a
vaccine so that you don't even have to
worry about it there you go
you have to get worse you have to get it
before you have sex so okay Lee Daly
from facebook says I've been hearing of
children and teenagers asking doctors to
be vaccinated without their parents
knowing
is it possible for doctors to do this or
would it be considered unethical
presumably they're minors yeah this is a
new trend where we only have anecdotal
reports
in various places around the United
States and in Europe but it does seem to
be happening and that is parents who
refuse to vaccinate their children at
the appropriate ages before age five now
those kids are growing up they're about
to go off to college where they will be
exposed and live in dorm rooms and so on
with other kids that potentially could
be carriers or they are carriers or they
might expose the other kids these are
kids who are more rational than their
parents were more rational than their
parents and are going to their
pediatrician and saying I want the shots
but if they're 12 can a pediatrician do
that no the pediatrician is going to
have to have a long conversation with
the parents okay so at age 18 can they
do it
yes in most states and in fact in many
states at 16 they can do it okay it just
depends on the state law all right it's
probably too late for many of these kids
if their parents are anti-vaxxers right
you know it's one of the things I say to
parents that express doubts I say do you
really think that when your child is 20
years old and now is ready to has
wanderlust and wants to travel and do
the thing that kids do in college travel
and go let's go to Morocco and check out
Algeria and Casablanca and blah blah
blah do you really think they're gonna
say thanks a lot mom and dad for making
me vulnerable to every single darn
disease I'm gonna be exposed to because
you refuse to let me get vaccinated okay
this is from JT our machine from
Instagram what is a measles what is Amy
that's what we asked the question when
you get the measles what the hell is
going on in your body wow that's a
really great question because measles is
so contagious and we have so much
history and we know a great deal about
what it does to the human body me when
measles gets in you inhale it it very
quickly goes through your lungs and into
your bloodstream so it is you know
almost immediately systemic but here's
the really tricky thing that makes it so
hard to conquer it you can be infected
and have no symptoms for a couple of
weeks so your carrier you're a carrier
and
you don't know it you're not being a bad
person you just don't know it's being an
awesome virus it's an awesome virus
because it it takes care of its host for
a really long time because if it killed
you instantly it wouldn't be able to
spread itself right well that's why
Ebola we have yet to have a world
epidemic of Ebola because you are
immediately debilitated you're so sick
you're not out chopping around and in
the case of measles people which so it
means the the best viruses from a human
survival standpoint are the most deadly
their essence the best viruses from
their own perspective no no I'm from my
perspective oh yeah
super deadly rabies rabies in the
absence of vaccine rabies is 100% deadly
to humans to all mammals
so you get exposed you die and it's fast
but you're not gonna give it to anybody
else because you're dead on the floor
you're dead and you have to bite them
you have to be affected and
cannibalistic but it in okay so what is
measles so the first symptoms of measles
would be very hard to distinguish
because it's fever its malaise it's a
key muscle all the stuff that is like oh
I have the flu it's similar until you
get the distinctive red splotches which
is petechiae and this is because your
capillaries are responding to the virus
and you get these little tiny red and
then the red splotches join and then
they look like big red you know I'm
gonna listen to you describe this
examining you have what's called medical
student disease and and then at that
point you're feverish and you're down
for the count you know and you're just
gonna tough it out and it really is just
is your immune system able to muster a
response or not when I was a child I had
measles and it was before there were
vaccines readily available I had
chickenpox I had rubella and Ruby Ola
so I went through the list and in every
ice-cream flavors bluebelly
and there were miserable experiences I
mean anybody that tries to minimize it
has just never been around it measles I
remember being so delirious that mother
would come in to the bedroom and I
wasn't sure it was her or a ghost or
some image from somewhere
you know I she would speak to me and I
couldn't hear and that's another thing
that people don't think about they they
look at something like measles and think
it's either lethal or not lethal well
there's you know the measles used to be
the number one cause of profound
deafness in America and a very high
percentage of people who get measles
will have permanent hearing loss it also
kills brain cells and a lot of people
will find that they are permanently
intellectually impaired by having
suffered from measles hey but you had
measles yeah so apparently it created
brain damage surprises by now no you're
just an idiot I was a finalist two other
time and shingles like shingles is that
everyone's questioning whether to get
the shingles vaccine Oh get it I've had
shingles oh good I'm shingles vaccinated
well I I had shingles I was it was in
1983 I had heard that she remembers the
day date time I was I was very young for
getting measles
I mean shingles it's usually considered
a problem for seniors but I was covering
the first documented cases of babies
with AIDS and this is in order in early
days of the AIDS epidemic and the
tragedy I was seeing living for weeks
among screaming crying children for whom
we had no treatment nothing and seeing
them separated from their dying parents
on another ward and it was so traumatic
I I came down with profound shingles
and it went right up my spinal cord and
believe me you do not want shingles so
your immune system was compromised in
your emotional state yes because the
chickenpox virus hides in your nerve
cells and so hence it's opportunistic
when you get older yes when you are more
susceptible yes and it's opportunistic
when you're under high stress hmm
another reason for me to stay calm okay
let's here let's do lightning round your
answers have to be really bites okay but
I don't know if that you can do that do
you have this power I do we'll be the
judge of that okay this is a long
question we should go okay I don't have
any shirt ones left okay Arlene calm
down okay start talk radio Jeanette
there is now an AI that can check to see
if a baby is autistic at six months old
with 96% accuracy if this a I can
predict autism at six months old at a
ninety-six percent rate but vaccines
aren't given till 12 months old
doesn't this completely kill the notion
that vaccines cause autism yes Kath
7-eleven Instagram those are somebody
that was great no question no doubt on
that okay given the current trend of
people moving away from vaccines how do
you approach anti-vaxxers I live in an
area with a high concentration of
anti-vaxxers and I'm finding it
increasingly difficult to sway their
opinions tell them that by not
vaccinating their children they're
putting your children at risk and that
that is not a fair way to participate in
democracy or be part of a community mmm
grace 22 Burroughs Instagram why aren't
all vaccines a hundred percent effective
oh goodness
that's a hard one to do really short but
let's just say it has to do with the
nature of the kind of immune response
that would be properly mounted in order
to defeat that microbe so let me follow
up are there any vaccines that are 100%
um well the Ebola vaccine looks to be a
hundred precise and what's the vaccine
is that sort of the lowest percent would
you say influenza influenza that's
because it's not matching the right
because two problems it's not matching
the right virus that's circulating
it's your inherent immune system memory
which is against whatever was the first
form of flu you were exposed to as a
baby mmm I have a question about flu cuz
someone said if you get the vaccine and
it's the same strand how come you're not
immune to it the second time around why
do you have to get the flu vaccine
because it never is the same no it'll be
the same family so like you we might say
there's an h1n1 flu circulating hope not
you and you might have been exposed to
h1n1 when it came through in 2009 which
was that huge global pandemic we had
right but school canceled but it's a
different h1n1 so your immune system
only partially recognizes it alright
okay next question
Merle at Merle from Twitter what is the
difference between a disease being
eliminated and eradicated ah I love that
mmm eliminated means it's you know not
in certain ways you know to ask that
question that's great it's smart person
good so eliminate it as it's not in
circulation in your given community
state nation how whatever group you're
defining eradicate it and we only have
eradicated one human pathogen small pox
means it doesn't exist on planet earth
anymore except in laboratories so people
are incorrect okay I'm old enough to be
that ends the lightning round
Laurie thanks for coming back yeah my
gosh I mean I don't like having you on
the show cuz it's about stuff that makes
me itch and crash and it's always it's
always apocalyptic but we need you it's
important in spite of this yeah so
Felicia where are you most active on
social media Instagram and Facebook okay
Felicia Madison comedian on both so we
can find you yes and uh do you tweet oh
I do
excuse me a lot excuse me and your
Twitter handle at Laurie underscore gear
we got it have you got it on you ain't
now we'll be looking for both of you
this has been star talk let's make
America smart again edition all about
vaccines I've been your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I thank glory and
Felicia and maybe we can do this again
when the next disease that we have to
eradicate comes up as always as always I
bid you to keep looking up
[Music]